a new study says global temperatures are
set to rise
beyond the target limit of 1.5 degrees
celsius
unless there are rapid and immediate
reductions in greenhouse gas emissions
the u.n climate panel predicts the
coming decades will bring more extreme
weather events like the floods and
wildfires
we've seen the past weeks the authors
say the report is a final reality check
as policymakers prepare for a crucial
climate summit
in november
let's bring in uh ajit niranjan from our
um
environment department the ipcc's
working group co-chair called this
report
a reality check what does he mean well
this report
shows with to the best scientific
evidence available
just how much one single species humans
have changed the planet in the space of
a few hundred years
and the changes that they find as you
said earlier they're widespread rapid
and intensifying and that means
everything from heat waves getting
hotter
to arctic ice melting and things that
will last well beyond our own lifetimes
so what's the message then to
governments around the world
so world leaders pledged the paris
agreement in 2015 they pledged to
limit global warming to well below 2
degrees celsius above pre-industrial
temperatures
and ideally to 1.5 degrees celsius and
this 1.5 degrees c
target that's going to be broached in
the next 20 years or so
and in all the scenarios that they
consider that these models kind of look
at
in all of these scenarios except for one
of them they
stay above 1.5 they keep getting worse
and the one in which we do manage to
bring
things back down by the end of the
century and kind of meet this 1.5 degree
c target
that involves rapidly decarbonizing the
economy
and sucking enormous amounts of co2 out
of the atmosphere
and governments so far aren't doing none
no and one of the kind of effects of
this means i mean firstly people need to
start adapting immediately so
as the report stresses climate change is
already here heat waves have already
gotten hotter
um some of the numbers on this are
actually quite
hard to believe i mean i've just got
this in front of me and
so i mean with one degree of the one
degree of warming that we've already
seen
a heat wave that used to hit once a
decade has become two
three times more likely now that doesn't
sound like so much but if we let warming
get
four degrees celsius above what what
they were before the industrial
revolution
and that's something that we're not
quite on track for but if we're unlucky
could still end up with
then that heat wave occurs nine times in
ten years
nine years out of ten if we look at the
heatwave that used to hit once every 50
years
here's where it gets really difficult to
wrap your head around at four degrees of
warming a heat wave that used to hit
once every 50 years
will occur 39.2 times
that is truly frightening um one expert
said
uh that this is the last ipcc assessment
that can make a real difference in
policy terms before we exceed 1.52
degrees celsius
so is it too late it's never too late
and all the scientists i've spoken to
have stressed
heavily that every single degree matters
every tenth of the degree matters
it's constantly a process of reducing
the amount of harm we have already
changed the climate
by burning fossil fuels heating the
atmosphere releasing gases that act like
a greenhouse
all of this has made weather conditions
more unpredictable it's made them worse
it's shifted kind of this distribution
of what we're experiencing
but if we stop burning fossil fuels then
we can stop these problems greenhouse
gas concentrations
will reduce in the atmosphere and that's
something that we can do something about
so reducing co2 and other greenhouse
gases is one thing and this is
probably the most important thing but at
adaptation to the effects of climate
change that we're already seeing
as well is are we doing enough for in
terms of adaptation
exactly so they are both important and
adaptation is something that's
so far not being talked about very much
and needs to be a big much bigger part
of the picture because
we are already experiencing the effects
of climate change as you said
and at the minute with like one degree
of warming or so
then good adaptation can actually make a
much bigger difference
the problem kind of for humanity i guess
is that
the more it warms the less you can adapt
there are limits to adaptation
if sea levels keep rising and we have
the multimeter sea level rise that's
kind of projected in the port
or at least that the report says it's
possible after the end of the centuries
he'll just keep writing
then how high can you build a seawall to
that yeah but in the short term
you need to do it i just from my
environment desk thank you very much
stay on the subject for nearly two weeks
turkey has been battling its most
destructive wildfires in living memory
the fires have forced the evacuation of
tens of thousands of people in southern
coastal regions
an estimated 100 000 hectares of
vegetation
have been destroyed president recep
tayyip erdogan
has come under fierce criticism for his
handling of the disaster
dw's julia hahn reports from milas on
the asian coast
thousands of ordinary turkish citizens
have been volunteering there to help
fight the fires
eren tamran is not a forest worker
he is a tech consultant from istanbul
a week ago he dropped everything and
rushed to southern turkey
to join the fight against the wildfires
now he and his friends are helping
authorities here in milas on the aegean
coast
to build fire breaks areas free of
vegetation
that act as barriers to stop the flames
from spreading
the fires grow very fast i have never
seen
anything like this before in some places
it really looks like scenes from hell
i couldn't just sit at home and watch i
had to come here and do something
chainsaws helmets protective glasses
erin and his friends have paid for the
equipment out of their own pockets
they are among thousands of volunteers
from across the country
who have joined efforts to contain the
blazes and help those affected
turkey hasn't seen such devastating
wildfires in decades
i believe that some of them were caused
intentionally but of course
the climate crisis and the hot weather
also play a role
when it all comes together it leads to
disaster
a disaster firefighters have been
struggling to get under control
over the past days dramatic scenes have
unfolded
as desperate villagers and volunteers
stepped in to help contain blazes
raging near their doorsteps
the extent of the destruction in the
fire hit regions
is unprecedented the flames have turned
huge tracts of forests and fields
into grey landscapes according to
estimates
at least 100 000 hectares have been
destroyed
an area bigger than the german capital
berlin
hardly any green trees as far as the eye
can see
and the people who survived this inferno
are increasingly asking
how could it come to this and what is
the government doing to make sure
it won't happen again local mayor
mohamed talked
a member of turkey's main opposition
party has been sounding the alarm for
days
the flames nearly destroyed a thermal
power plant in his district
on this parking lot he and his team are
now coordinating aid
for those affected by the fires torkat
says
the region did not receive the help
needed from the central government
we are in a very dramatic situation it's
unacceptable
that a powerful state like turkey does
not own any functioning firefighting
planes
we wouldn't have lost that much forest
if we had more planes ready
when the blazes first erupted we are
facing a worst case scenario
and we were not prepared for it
in the forest of milas erin tamran and
his friends are taking a short break
they have been working non-stop the few
last days
in temperatures of around 40 degrees
celsius
but now isn't the time for
recriminations aaron says
now's the time to help stop the flames
from spreading
and save what's left of turkey's forests
i mean while massive wildfires in
neighboring greece have left hundreds of
people homeless as well and forced
thousands to evacuate
on the island of avia many residents
have been brought to safety by ferries
while
others have stayed behind to help the
firefighters
more and more people in greece are
talking about the fire of the century
in three regions wildfires are burning
their way
through forests and towns north of
athens
in the peloponnese and on the island of
evia
rescue workers and residents are
exhausted as they fight the inferno
the extreme heat and strong winds keep
fanning the flames
firefighting aircraft are only now able
to reach some of the devastated areas
the planes were needed to protect athens
where the situation is now stabilizing
meanwhile on evia the island is divided
by a wall
of fire ferries and naval ships are on
standby to evacuate any remaining
residents
many people in hardhead regions are
angry that there wasn't more support to
fight the fires
nothing
despite evacuation orders many residents
stayed behind
to defend their homes often with only a
garden hose
as part of an international effort
emergency crews from germany and across
europe have been dispatched to greece
but locals are asking why so few of
greece's
own firefighting aircraft were ready for
action
when the fires first ignited
you